so what I really want to take from your
research is an idea that this
pro-democracy nationalism inoculates
against the anti do not democracy
nationalism but when I think of the
riots in Gujarat which happened 20 years
after independence and five years before
that the time period you're talking
about and the rise of the BJP today I
can't take away that message so sort of
what is what is the message that I can
take away about the difference and the
interplay of these two types of
nationalisms yeah it's a great question
and let's better said than what I was
trying to write right so I guess what I
would say is that the word inoculates is
far too strong all the explanations that
political scientists have for when
democracy does or doesn't come about
they're all probabilistic explanations
they're not that's nothing not a super
diverse ethnic group a super high level
of Economic Development nothing is an
ABS is absolutely sufficient to become a
democracy so the claim that I'm making
is that all else being equal and of
course nothing else is pretty cool right
because countries are very particular
and spaces and time or space and time
specific creations but that all else
being equal a relatively flat and open
porous conception of what it means to be
a member of that nation is a resource
for democracy because of subsequent
moments of political crisis when you
have political entrepreneurs pushing to
get to power they if there is by
contrast a narrative of nation that
Creek that specifically sets aside a
group as not being core to defining the
nation that a moments of crisis that
particular group can be more easily
targeted by politicians and power and
that's what you see happening with
Muslims in right there were Hingis in me
Maur it's what you see today happening
in India and what you saw when Modi was
the Chief Minister of Gujarat which is
when the riots that you mentioned
happened he was very much been pushing a
Hindu nationalist vision and it's not a
coincidence that's exactly where you saw
the riots happening in India because
it's where the chief politician in power
was pushing a majoritarian view of what
it meant to be a citizen of that nation
so to go back to your question what do I
take away from this talk it's not that
anything inoculates democracy and
democracy is only as strong as our
belief in it and our willingness
essentially make sacrifices on behalf of
a particular way of organizing and
sharing power but what I can say is that
in addition to all those structural
factors which to make democracy a little
bit more likely so if you're a little
bit wealthier a little bit more likely
if you don't have a oil and gas as a
major part of your export democracy is a
little more likely and what I want to
add to the conversation is when you have
a nationalism that's relatively
egalitarian it makes democracy a little
more likely for the reasons I mentioned
right so I think that's another yeah
yeah yeah so just briefly I think that
that was that was a question I was sure
I was gonna get so high you know when
you're talking about one nationalism or
there are lots of kinds of nationalists
and I think that's absolutely true
founding moments provide particularly
powerful narratives of what the nation
is but of course those narratives are
contested and changing over time but it
you know they're often surprisingly
durable and what you see you happening
in India right now is a sustained
attempt to change what the national
identity is and to the extent that it
endures its empower it begins to change
national curriculums and which you know
is exactly what we're seeing that will
become a resource for essentially
promoting one form of democratic
breakdown just when those Civil and
Political liberties are systematically
denied to the out groups
you
[Music]